It turns out that it would only take 15 minutes. Nice algebra skills if you got
that one correct. We know in the first case, we're driving for 20 minutes at 45
miles per hour. So 20 minutes would be time 1, and 45 miles per hour would be
rate 1. We're looking for how long it takes for the car to travel the same
distance. So this must be x, our time 2. And for the second rate, we're
traveling at 60 miles per hour, so we fill in this with 60. Then, we cross
multiply to get 900 equals 60x. We divide both sides by 60 to get x is equal to
15, or 15 minutes. The key for these inverse variation problems is that one
quantity will be in the numerator while the other will be in the denominator. We
usually flip the second fraction to make that happen.